A new wave of Russian strikes on Kiev.
Ukraine says its air defense system
intercepted 36
missiles and drones over the capital city
early Friday.
At least two people were injured.
Meanwhile, multiple explosions
have been reported in a Russian occupied
port city in southern Ukraine.
A Ukrainian official
says Russian positions have been hit.
And this comes as Russian border
regions are struck by fresh attacks.
Sam Kiley joining us.
Sam, a new wave of these hits towards
Kiev.
Many of these missiles intercepted
and frankly, a lot of activity in Russian
occupied territories as well as what
we're seeing inside of Russia.
This week, there's been so much activity
Yes, Elena.
What we've can see now is very obviously
a new campaign conducted by the Ukrainians
or on the behalf of the Ukrainians,
Ukrainians inside Russia.
They're not taking any direct
responsibility for the invasion or raids
being carried out by Russian nationals
who are badged
effectively to the Ukrainian armed forces
crossing into Belgorod region.
But that's just what they have done with
the local authorities in Russia, saying
two people are being killed in a bombing
or mortar attacks in frontline villages.
At the same time in Smolensk,
another Russian city
north of Kiev.
The oil refinery has been hit by
what is assumed to be a drone attack
similar to the one that hit in Krasnodar
south of the country.
So there is a pattern emerging here
on top of the pattern
that is long preexisting,
which is the systematic targeting,
particularly of key, particularly of
civilians by the Russians inside Ukraine.
Now, this is having a strategic effect.
The campaign inside Russia,
with Vladimir Putin coming out today
saying that essentially
I'm paraphrasing here,
we mustn't get rattled, we mustn't
allow them to destabilize Russia.
But that's exactly
what these relatively small scale attacks
inside Russian territory
are intended to do to destabilize
the Russian effort with Ukraine.
Making all kinds of claims about
the movement of Russian special forces
into that area, which are unverifiable
but again, are intended
whether they're true or false,
to sow unease, discomfort
and dismay among the Russian forces
as they continue to threaten to prosecute
a campaign, a counter offensive inside
Ukraine to recapture lost territory.
But I think we should see these campaigns
inside Russian territory
as the early stages
of their counter offensive
Sam Kiley, great to have you on.
Thank you so much.
And we're now joined by Timothy Miller,
one off.
He is the president
of the Keefe School of Economics, and
he is coming to us right now from Kiev.
It's very nice to see you.
And we want to try and get the measure
of what it's been like the last
few nights, especially as Russia continues
its assault.
I mean, could you ever imagine
that you and your fellow citizens
would be under this kind of siege
now almost a year and a half
after this invasion began?
Yeah, when the start when the war started,
I would all hope that would end first.
But several months into the war, you know,
I think
too many of us came
a realization that might go on forever.
And we know how brutal Russia is,
especially after the early revelation
and butcher and car.
So I'm not surprised they're trying
to target civilians with missiles.
But let me tell you, this last month
was really, really difficult.
I think everyone cannot sleep.
Everyone is traumatized.
We have been through maybe 18,
19 attacks in the last 30, 32 days.
This is brutal every night.
I expect to be awake at 3 a.m.
being afraid of missiles.
Yeah.
And I can imagine when you're dealing
with all of that after so many months,
and then some people are in their home
with young children,
with elderly, with disabled people.
It must just strike terror in so many
people, night after night after night.
It strikes
maybe not terror, but fear fear
for the loved ones and excuse me.
And then anger at Russia.
Now, you argue
that Ukraine needs to prosecute this war
itself.
Defend itself.
But, you know, you kind of are saying
in a way, and you have been for months now
that Ukraine cannot submit
to this state of war.
For one thing,
you've been advocating that the rebuilding
should actually start now. Why?
I mean,
you can understand the reluctance, right,
of international partners who are saying
you know, especially under the barrage
that you've had the last few weeks,
this is not a good time
to think about rebuilding the country.
Well, that's because when people are far
from the situation itself,
they tend to simplify.
They simply don't have enough context,
enough visuals and not emotions.
For them, it's a war.
And then there will be at the end
of the war and then we will rebuild.
But on the ground
is something very different.
You have a clinic.
Clinic has been destroyed.
People have to continue to get care.
For example, cancer
patients have to get treatment.
Otherwise, what?
They will die.
People with heart attacks
have to get treatment.
And brought to the hospitals quickly
in time to be safe.
So we need those facilities now.
When we talk about recovery
during the war, we actually not talking
about rebuilding some kind of grand vision
of the future of Ukraine during the war.
But we are talking about maintaining
the economy, maintaining the resilience,
providing people
with services that they need right now.
You know,
one of
the ways that you've been communicating
with other people in Ukraine,
but mostly the world or your Twitter feeds
and you always gives such an intimate view
of your life there during wartime.
I want to talk about what you posted
recently because it took many by surprise.
You know, it was just video phone
video of a normal day at the McDonald's.
You can see it there.
You're walking with the phone.
10 million people viewed it.
What do you make of the reaction
that you got from this?
The reaction, quote, was polarizing.
Some people said, listen, this is great.
Ukraine is resilient.
This is another example that they're like
cos they continue
to go about their lives as normal.
And we have to support them.
We stand with Ukraine.
But others said, listen, guys,
it looks like completely normal.
There is no war.
War is a fake.
Don't send us our taxpayers money to it.
And I engaged with
some of the people on Twitter,
and some of them are very, very anti
Ukrainian and pro-Russian people.
And we talked privately and publicly.
And I think they sort of slowly start
coming about
because their impression is
then when there is a war
that must be that everything is destroyed
and people are in shelters, all the time.
But that's not how it is
when the attack stops.
Kiev comes out to war or any city in
Ukraine, any village almost immediately.
I think it's our point.
We are trying to make this clear
that we will continue to war.
We will continue to leave.
And this is our answer.
Civil lands to the Russian terror.
And I think it's sometimes difficult
to understand from afar,
but I'm glad that some of my tweets
make this discussion public.
Yeah.
Going to McDonald's, getting ice cream,
sitting on some of those patios
in Ukraine, its very own
form of resistance during this conflict.
Timothy, thanks so much.
Really appreciate you being with us.
And we'll continue to check in with you.